good evening
welcome to this meeting of the audit
committee
i will now read out the emergency
evacuation announcement can you hear me
all right
should we be required to evacuate the
building would you please leave the
building via the entrance doors to the
hall continue straight on and exit the
building via the double doors on the
right to the car park which is the
assembly point
please do not delay your evacuation to
collect any belongings
please do not return to the building
until given permission to do so by
council staff
please note that the meeting will be
audio recorded
please switch off mobiles or turn them
to silent
members there are four microphones on
the tables for use during the meeting
when i invite you to speak please wait
until there is a microphone in front of
you before speaking
as microphones are needed for the
hearing loop and for audio recording
please where possible assist in passing
microphones to each other
use the hand gel and antibacterial wipes
on the tables if you do touch the
microphones
voting will be done on a show of hands
in line with the constitution
i will ask for a show of hands for and
against
the recommendations and will then ask
for any abstention abstentions
is that understood yes
right agenda item one apologies for
absence
we haven't received any apologies in the
office is are there any
no
agenda item two substitute
members none have been notified
no
agenda item three non-members attending
there are none
agenda item 4 minutes of the meeting
held on the 16th of march 2021
are the minutes agreed members
agenda item five to receive declarations
of interest are there any declarations
of interest members
no
agenda item six questions on notice
there are none
agender item seven motions on notice
there are none
agenda item eight
external auditor report certification of
claims and returns annual report 2019-20
assistant director naomi lucas will
present this report
thank you chair
um the purpose of this um report is to
draw members attention to the
certification of claims and annual
um sorry in annual returns um in
accordance with the department for work
and pension requirements the council
must appoint an external auditor to
certify the accuracy of the housing
benefits subsidy claim
and in 2019-20 the external auditor was
bgo
the reports of bdo is appended and
summarizes the work on behalf of
rochefort district council's 1920
housing benefits subsidy claim
as a result of the work carried out bdo
checks and certified the council's
housing benefit subsidy claim which has
a total value of 13.2 million pounds
they have issued a qualification letter
as a result of some minor errors that
they found but the total value of those
errors was only 157 pounds
and when those errors are extrapolated
out that results in a further possible
adjustment of 19 pounds
so members will note that that's not
material in comparison to the overall
value of the claim
in terms of the fee page for this work
um the fee for 2019 20 was 15
650 pounds
which is slightly less than the fee page
last in the previous year
and this was as a result of the lower
error rates
in this year's claim
so as i said the more detailed report is
appended
and happy to try and answer any
questions that members may have but the
report is just for noting thank you
councillor gadsden
thank you
um i just want to be new to the audit
committee there are a few things i'd
like to understand a little more
um on page
9.10 and it states assurance rating no
opinion given no opinion given and then
it says
um
apologies but i think that's um a
different item on the agenda are we not
sorry
i thought we'd pass that
cancer dry
can wait for the microphone
um thank you madam chairman obviously a
very involved report
but uh i apologize i've missed this in
the report but um i'd like to know how
many claimants there are for housing
benefit
and the average benefit per claimant
also a note
was
noted in the presentation that there are
errors for both under and overpayment
are those errors rectified back to the
individual claimants
and at the time of clement making a
claim
are there any checks made at that time
with regards to any fraudulent claims or
possible fraudulent claims
uh thank you councillor i might pass
over to um
jim in a sec and
just to say yeah i don't know offhand
the total number of claimants i don't
know if
jim does okay so i'll let him answer
that one um and um
yeah actually i've just my mind's gone
blank on the second bit but let me pass
it over to jimin
can you hear me
yes
um
during the uh
2019-20 period uh there was 112 new
rents allowance cases
that's uh ordinary housing benefit and
94 temporary accommodation claims
and during the year there were 16 180
changes in circumstances
there was an average caseload of 2490
and of for rent allowances and 95
families in temporary accommodation i'm
fred i don't know the average claim but
it it it depends on the individual rents
uh for some first like uh council's
social housing it's around 150 pounds a
week
for private rentals it can be three or
four hundred pound a week depending on
the individual circumstances
okay
okay
can you hear me now sorry right
i know where to sit now right i'm sorry
i'll repeat that again
uh during
2019-20 there were 112
new rent allowance cases and 94 new
temporary accommodation cases
with 16 180 changes in circumstances
which would affect an individual claim
and there was an average case load of
2490 rents allowance and 95 temporary
accommodations
as that the average
value will depend on the circumstances
of individual claimants
depending on whether they're in private
rental or social housing
um
during any any testing identified errors
within the
for the audit the work i do and the work
that the external auditors do
adjustments will be made usually the
errors
of overpayments tend to be
errors by the council so we don't get
them we don't claim those back and any
underpayments are certainly adjusted
okay
um fraud wise
we do identification checks as much as
possible we
when a new case is started there will be
inquiries made with the dwp to see if
there's only what's being paid
and they do keep an eye out ongoing for
any potential for cases
um is it
down to the individual claims to let let
you know they're changing circumstances
and is there a maximum period of time
that anybody can make a claim
no as long as the circumstances meet the
requirements for a claim then the claim
will be paid and it is
it is the responsibility of the claimant
to make a change should a claim come to
light that's when the case will be
looked at for potential overpayments
thank you
any further questions
against this lauren shaw
thank you chairman
do the wdwp actually advise you of
changing circumstances um whether
they've got the universal credit or any
other claimants pip or anything else uh
yes councillor when the uh when a
claimant
receives universal credit uh that we
receive a notification electronically
from the dwp
and that advises that uh someone who's
on housing benefit will be moving across
usually they're allowed a 14-day carry
forward of the housing benefits until
the universal credit sort itself out but
after that housing benefit will cease to
working age claimants thank you
any further questions
[Music]
sorry can you just remind me does it it
does say in a report somewhere how much
we actually get back from dwp doesn't it
i did just yeah the claim was for 13.2
million
there no further questions
there is one recommendation set out at
paragraph 7.1 on page 8.1 of the report
that the certification of claims and
returns annual report
2019-20 be noted
is that noted members
agenda item 9
internal order annual report 2020 to
2021
um chief audit executive mike porter
will present the report please
thank you chair
can anyone everyone hear me
okay thank you
as the council's chief audit executive
i'm required to produce an annual report
and opinion that can be used to inform
the council's governance statement
the opinion itself must conclude on the
overall adequacy and and effectiveness
of the council's arrangements for
governance risk management and internal
control
the opinion is actually derived from the
work we carry out during the course of
the year
and other sources of assurance provided
to myself
the audit committee actually receives a
number of regular progress reports on
delivery against the audit plan
and is informed of changes to the plan
these changes were
notified to the committee in november
2020 and again in march 2021
appendix one at 9.7 provides a summary
of the internal audit work complete
during the course of the year
since the last audit committee in march
a further seven audit engagements have
been completed relating to 2021
these are set out at appendix 2.
a total of 19 audit engagements were
completed during 20 20 21
three of these audit engagements
received limited assurance opinion
13 inadequate or good opinion and three
where no opinion was provided in
relation to those three audits where no
actually opinion is provided these
relate to grant certification work
where an audit opinion is not required
and also in relation to consultancy work
in relation to also counter fraud work
the council continues to make
significant cashable savings for the
council both in terms of council tax and
business rates
also during the 2021 the council process
a wide range of business related grants
these are also subject to review by
internal audit and no significant issues
were identified
despite making changes to the plan
during the course of the year this
revised plan has not affected my ability
to provide an opinion
sufficient work has still been completed
during the year to enable you to provide
an android opinion
in terms of the opinion for 2021 there's
no change from the previous year in that
on providing adequate assurance that the
council's arrangements were risk
management internal control and
governance
generally are concord with best practice
and are fundamentally sound
there are some
opportunities for improvements and these
are identified in the annual government
statement
i'm quite happy to take any questions
you may have
cancer sure
thank you thank you in um item 9
appendix 1 there are
good limited adequate of the council now
ensuring that we get these to good
please
um we don't actually review or take a
further look at an audit engagement so
we don't actually revise that opinion
what we do is basically make a number of
recommendations and basically monitor
implementation those recommendations so
if we were to take that
audit again we would hope that with the
implementation the recommendations that
the assurance rating would go up but we
don't actually change the rate and
provided at the time of audit
we would be subject to enough audit
itself so we would have to take another
audit and provide enough opinion
so effectively we don't provide a
revised opinion
thank you so we don't got you don't go
back and address the ones that have
are unlimited or adequate at this stage
you will do it next year
we wouldn't necessarily do it again what
we do is make sure the recommendations
made in relation to that audit are
followed up so the control weaknesses
identified
are addressed so basically where we're
saying there's a weakness or a problem
with this error we would make a
recommendation we would then check that
that recommendation is implemented
therefore if we were to
issue a revised report
the opinion would be changed but we
don't issue a revised report right thank
you
councillor drei
thank you uh madam chairman
i note i think it's appendix 4 in
progress of all recommendations
there are
a number of implementer implementation
dates um some of which have been
extended in one case
the extension date was over a year and
i'm just wondering
if there's any authorization
needed for such an extension or if that
is reported anywhere to members of the
uh council
yes i mean what would happen is that
this service department would come back
to internal audit and ask for an
exchange an extension and we would
consider the reasons why there's a need
for
to move the date in effect i mean
during covert
there's been other priorities so the
council were focused on efficacy on
other activities so a large number of
the audit recommendations themselves
have been pushed back
but these are generally the low priority
recommendations if they're significant
or major recommendations they would be
implemented within the first three
months so the ones that are generally
being pushed back because of other
priorities like kobe 19
or the council's response to kovid are
there any ones that have been pushed
back the low priority
once okay
through you madam chairman perhaps i can
suggest that any long-term further
extension of implementation date uh be
reported back to the audit committee as
and when required so that we can keep an
eye on things as well instead of it
coming to this
uh this state and this report i i think
they often are aren't they
but yeah the base the the table
presented here in the end report that's
partly the courtney progress reports so
that this is repeated every quarter so
you'll get sight of this progress to
this table
every quarter so every three months
you'll you'll get to see the
recommendations okay that's that's fine
one other observation
also
it notes in a report there's there's
been a possible fraud or there's a
possibility of fraud whereby invoices
are being paid where there is no valid
order now that signals danger to me um
is that being rectified
in order to to stop that practice
[Music]
german um
there were two audits we did this year
one was on procurement which were
identified sometimes they're not raising
orders
before we get the invoice
but we have a policy where invoices are
not paid unless there is an order
and testing within the creditor's audit
found this to be the case
so we have a degree of protection on
that one
and all the orders that we have in those
in that category i think it's down to
people
trying to sort of do things quickly
rather than doing anything
untoward and i've never not come across
any evidence of anything that was not
purchased uh anything that was purchased
that wasn't required or part of the
processes okay
thank you
thank you madam chairman
councillor gaston
um in that case does that mean there's a
delay in us paying our suppliers
unfortunately that can be the case yes
because the invoices have returned to
the service area to raise the orders and
it is affecting the performance which i
think is highlighted in the procurement
report on
page might have been the previous might
have been the previous audio
i'm sorry i think i actually might have
been on it on page 9.18.
so any further questions
um i was only going to follow up by
saying that i feel that you know
this is a consideration that we need to
maybe act quicker on because larger
suppliers can obviously take delays but
small businesses this would impact
greatly on and
whilst i understand the explanation that
people do
try to cut corners in order to be
quicker and to deal with the tasks i've
got to do i do feel that sometimes small
players suppliers this could impact on
greatly
it's a concern
[Music]
i can't just add something to that i
mean i think one of the things is to
make sure that
purchase orders are actually raised up
front because that is the process
you raise a purchase order you then
produce the grn so basically it's about
education making sure actually these
purchase orders are being raised at the
right time and therefore when an invoice
comes in it's matched to the goods
received and automatically paid so it's
about educating service departments
actually to basically produce that
purchase order at the right time um can
i also say it's about management control
i mean it's one thing having training
employees but it's also about
supervision and management and i think
that's
one of their functions to make sure
these things are done
yes thank you
yes we'll we'll note that
councillor lauren shaw
thank you thank you as going from
uh councillor gaddison and councillor
dryer i find it very concerning that we
are actually
we have staff
and management must be authorizing these
staff to go out and order items that we
haven't got orders for and they're not
getting i thought we should have three
recorded um quotes
and it seems that we're not having them
so i think this is an area we've
certainly got to look at thank you
to the chair the
this partic particular audit was
restricted to purchases of up to ten
thousand pound where there was a lower
level of proof uh anything over ten
thousand pound uh prior testing has
shown that to be working in line with
the instructions it's the smaller
transactions and although it's ten
thousand pound limit the majority of
these are in the sort of lower thousands
or
higher hundreds
can i come back please
yeah it may be a small level but we've
got to always remember this is our
resident's money
not our own money and we've got to be
mindful that we are using this bro
properly when we go through budgets
we're always asked to find ways of
keeping our budget in order which we've
done
but if we're getting
a couple of thousand pound here a couple
of thousand pound there without purchase
orders
or proper quotes we can lose the plot on
this and i don't i personally don't
think this is acceptable thank you
um is it okay if i just come back on
that and
yeah i was just gonna say um
obviously the council does take a
risk-based approach in terms of the
level of order and the proportionality
of the checks it undertakes um i don't
repeat what jim's just said but
obviously there's a lower kind of burden
of um
checking and proof that's required for
small value orders um and we haven't had
any evidence to suggest the larger
orders that there's non-compliance but i
do accept the point that there should be
compliance at all levels but the um the
number of quotes that's required for for
this lower level of expenditure um is
not always necessary to obtain three
quotes for for that level of expenditure
um but nonetheless this has been a sort
of continuing theme out of the
procurement audit so it is something
that we continue to um educate as
mike said in terms of training um so
that all all members of staff are aware
of the requirements on them thank you
so can i come back
um
so
so can i ask um with
staff reviews is this sort of thing that
you log and check over that they're
making progress that they're not
continuing with the same
um
problems or issues with this
yes thank you councillor we do have
regular updates at leadership
team and our procurement officer does
provide a regular update report in terms
of compliance and we do follow up on
specific instances and non-compliance
to identify why those have occurred and
try to address those so yes we do have
regular information on that so you say
you're monitoring staff
and with your hands on their reviews
um well we monitor at a kind of service
level and where there's individual
instances we would follow up as
appropriate with individual officers and
if there was obviously um
repeats kind of offenders if you like
then we would take that up with the
individual concern okay
because
everybody happy with that
any further questions
so there's one recommendation set out at
paragraph 12 of this report
that the chief audit executive's opinion
on the overall adequacy and
effectiveness of the council systems of
governance risk management and internal
control be noted
is that noted members
agenda item 10 draft annual government
statement for 2020-21
jim cavani will present the report
please
thank you chairman
this report introduces the annual
governance statement for
2020-21 this is a public assessment on
how effective we believe our government
governance arrangements were during the
past year including the systems of
internal control and management of risk
this remains a live document until the
accounts for 2020-21
are signed off by internal audit and may
require an update by that time this is
the reason for the recommendation number
two on page 10.3
starting on page 10.7 there is a general
narrative of the key governance issues
that impacted on the year and statements
from the head of paid service head of
finance the monitoring officer and the
chief audit executive whose annual
report presented as agenda item 9
tonight forms a key part of that
assessment the statement also reflects
input from the leadership team as a
whole
in november last year this committee
approved the revised local code of
corporate governance
this assessment from page 10.14
measures compliance against this code
in prior years there was a bulky
narrative for this section but this year
we have tried to create a more visual
approach which we believe helps to
clarify compliance and areas for
improvement
it must be remembered that this is an
assessment of governance and not a
report on all that was done by the
council across the year
on page 10.24 there is an update on
matters that were identified as
governance issues going into the gear
and the table at 10.27 details issues to
be considered going into 2021-22
thank you
any questions members
no questions
[Music]
members there are two recommendations
set out at paragraph 11.1 on page 10.3
of the report
number one is that the annual governance
statement for 2020
be endorsed and referred to the acting
manager director and leader of the
council for signature
and number two that the authority is
delegated to the chair of the audit
committee to endorse non-significant
changes to the age annual government
statement following review by the
council's external auditors
are you happy to take these
recommendations on block
those members in favor please raise your
hands
thank you members please lower your
hands
all right
can those members against please raise
their hands
so can you now please vote for those
recommendations
those in favor
that's unanimous thank you
agenda item 11
review of the council's risk register
2021-2022
our assistant director of resources
naomi lucas will present the report
thank you cher
this report
is one that is presented to audit
committee members twice a year
and presents the council's corporate
risk register for your consideration
the last version of the register was
presented in november 2020 at that point
we actually did a review of all of the
corporate risks um particularly in light
of um kovid 19.
since that date
we've
reviewed um half of those
risks um which are detailed in paragraph
3.5
and and the second half of those risks
will be reviewed in the the following
six months
um so the corporate risk register itself
is summarized on page 11.6 of the report
and then the detailed
risks are then
set out
in the following pages
there hasn't been a huge amount of
updates required to the corporate risk
register since it was last brought to
audit committee the only risk which has
been amended is risk for
incident response which has been updated
to reflect the completed migration to
the cloud-based it system for the
council
and
to
consider remote working practices which
have reduced the risks associated with
it and business continuity
the other risks although they have been
reviewed by the risk owners have not
resulted in any updates
at this point in time
the report just details
a few of the corporate risks which
have a high residual risk rating
and the risks themselves detail the
control measures that are put in place
to help manage those risks
um but even so yeah for health and
safety risk 3b
risk 9
balanced budget and risk 10 inability to
recruit and retain all of those risks
retain a high residual risk rating um
even though there are controls in place
to help manage those
finally section 5 just note some of the
key kind of strategic risks facing the
council
including kovid 19 and
the impacts of the uk's exit from the
european union
so the report is just for noting i
believe but if anyone has got any
questions i'm happy to try and answer
them thank you
any questions members
no questions
right members there is one
recommendation set out at paragraph
14.1 on page 11.4 of the report
that the contents of the corporate risk
register for 2021 be noted
members is that noted
i would like to thank
um naomi and jim and mike for their
presentations tonight and all the staff
for their continued work
with getting this done
but that now concludes the business for
this evening and the meeting is now
closed at 8.04
thank you everybody thank you
you